obviously we came here with our own set
of values
and the way you know the way we
we deal with
other people uh in our society and then
you come to new zealand where the
culture is so
different like people are laid back you
know there's no strict uh
boundaries in your roles
like what i found very different is that
in the philippines when you work in an
organization there's a specific
structure of authority like a flow of
authority and communication when i
arrived here
it's basically a flat organization so i
moved into a farm there's the farm owner
and then everything everybody else is
like this although they have different
skills and experience
so it's very hard to to
to move because you don't know where
your boundaries are in terms of your
role
you